bonjour monsieur vous allez bien
que lui arrive-t-il il m'a même pas dit
bonjour
aux messies 10,9 alors comment s'est
déroulé ce match de tennis
ma chaise
ah oui le soleil tapait taper très très
fort et
alors vous allez servir
vous avez fait des coups droits aux à
federer
mais vous aviez très chaud évidemment
avec un seul appareil
et vous avez fini victorieux bravo aux
l'a complètement épuisé mon corps
et puis et bien vous êtes rentré chez
vous
vous avez pris froid monsieur lune à
bord ou comme un
jeu comprend rien ne subsiste à
m'excuser motion je comprends rien petit
bois à vous avez mangé des petits pois
c'était bon
ah oui mais j'ai compris nous vous êtes
rentrés par le petit bois ces petits
noirs
nous monsieur des snobs ne dit rien j'ai
compris vous avez pris un show et froid
et oui vous êtes à phone feat télé venez
vous asseoir confirmé chez du snapo je
connais remède excellent on prend un
verre de lait tient chaud avec du miel
et on laval je vais demander à julie que
vous en préparer un pardon verrez c'est
un remède très très efficace vous avez
guérir
bonjour julie tu as l'air en pleine
forme et casimir jetons queen ne me
distrait pas trop parce que le bateau
part dans une heure il faut que je
remplisse tout mais bon de commande il
me manque des jouets des boissons des
bonbons de toutes sortes enfin c'est
bien simple je n'ai plus rien et je
travaille depuis ce matin depuis ce
matin
moi aussi je me suis levé très tôt ce
matin avec une envie terrible d'écrire
un poème il était tellement peau quand
les escargots dormaient encore enroulés
dans leur coquille dans mon jardin
alors j'ai pris un petit déjeuner très
très simple pour être en pleine forme
pour écrire tout simplement un grand bol
de chocolat avec une douzaine de deux
croissants au beurre d'anchois oui mais
enfin mais tu ne m'écoutes pas joli mais
si si si je t'écoute d'attaché pas vrai
tu continues à remplir tes papiers mais
enfin casimir je peux faire deux choses
à la fois il faut pas me sous-estimer
car on tient je t'écoute alors voilà mon
poème j'ai seulement écrit deux pages
jusqu'à présent voilà le début
sur le port tout est calme
les pêcheurs prochain les dormeurs d'orb
les passants pas à ça le peintre peint
le coiffeur coiffe le val siva anta les
mouches se mouchant et le chat joue
c'est beau hein c'est très joli mais
alors moi personnellement
j'ai déjà dit il faut absolument aider
monsieur 10 nov il ne peut plus parler
c'est pour ça qu'il ne m'a pas dit
bonjour ce matin il peut plus parler du
tout à peine je voudrais que de lui
prépare un verre de lait très chaud avec
du miel il a la voix cassée ça lui fera
beaucoup de bien mais alors s'il a la
voix cassée il voudrait beaucoup mieux
qu'il avale un tube de colle sa lumière
collera à la voie à
hauteur de présenter mon vieux il avait
la voix cassée ou un chat dans la gorge
comme monsieur du snob devrait pas ça
très agréable et assez voilà sur l'e
shop est prêt portant le 8 févr
non mais vous avez vous joly n'a même
pas le temps d'écouter ma toile jusqu'au
bout mais elle attend préparant les pour
monsieur du snob
et puis qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire de chat dans la gorge il faut
vraiment être aussi bête comme celui
snap pour avaler un chat
elle a préparé au lait pour le chat
qu'il a avalé mais moi aussi j'adore le
lait avec du miel et de la moutarde
mais ça ne se passera pas comme ça moi
aussi je vais avoir un chat dans la
gorge
et on a j'ai faim j'ai drôlement fait il
compte il me reste justement une vitre
un hymne un artichaut
oui mais moi j'aime pas ça les légumes
qu'est-ce que tu es à moi ce que j'aime
c'est du bon pain frais avec du beurre
et de la confiture
et compte est bon nous allons nous en
occuper tiens on a justement monsieur
martin qui sort de la boulangerie et il
a une baguette sous le bras wait
ou le monde a le sien one on image je
crois
ayant encore droit joli couac hawaii et
ont provoqué jaune dans ce monde insensé
de méchant
c'est
une question monsieur martin que voyez
vous pour que commence à ce que je vois
changement de me dire tout simplement ce
que vous voyez mais même là quel endroit
eh bien je vois je vois les jo je te
vois quoi au nord le renard est derrière
quoi je vois qu'on a mis qu'obama pas
vous voyez que vous voyez quelque chose
dans votre chanson vous dites je crois
ce que je vois et encore quelquefois je
n'y croit qu'à moitié vous ne croyez pas
que moi tient moins je ne suis pas une
moitié si je n'étais qu'une moitié moi
et mon ami tu en bas ne serions qu'un
alors que nous sommes deux noms mais je
ne vois pas ce que tu veux dire je ne
comprends absolument pas permettez
permet d'y prêter moi votre baguette je
vais essayer d'illustrer ma
démonstration d'un exemple week obama
merci que voyez-vous monsieur martin
mieux je vois une bête moubarak
est maintenant monsieur martin peu voyez
vous
je vois que vous avez cassé ma boîte et
ont deux records une certain culot
ensemble vous moi dit de deux manières
de pain vous dit croire que la moitié de
ce qu'on voyait alors le croyez qu'à la
moitié de baguette d'ailleurs vous aurez
bien passé d'une demie baguette pour
butiner la prochaine fois essayez de
voir double jeu sera plus avantageux
c'est bien
bon appétit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un ami
j'avais comme comme des mèches comme un
chat dans la gorge
et vous chers amis comme une expression
imagée dit bien ce qu'elle veut dire
avoir un chat dans la gorge et quoi
commence la visite il arrive aux
vêtements les vêtements oui après un
match extraordinaire de tennis dans
lequel j'ai eu très chaud eh bien j'ai
oublié de me couvrir alors en passant
par le petit bois évidemment claque je
chat dans la gorge
tiens bon je m'envoie casimir tu vas
bien
non mais tu peux pas parler toi non plus
haut
tout un riff qui tu étais très bien
quoi tu as un chat dans la gorge doit
aussi
que vous ne trouvez pas qu'il a une
drôle d'expression comme ça avec la la
bouche entrouverte
vous pensez vraiment qu'il est aphone
regardez on dirait qu'il veut nous dire
quelque chose ah j'ai compris il veut
vous dire que le chat qu'il a dans la
gorge était non il est très gros oui
dis-moi casimir est ce que tu ne
voudrais pas par hasard un un petit lait
chaud avec du miel
quoi ignares mais c'est la première fois
que j'entends casimir me auger je trouve
même qu'il miaule très clairement pour
quelqu'un dans wii regardez je crois que
casimir cache quelque chose dans sa
bouche tu as raison julie des émirs
l'histoire reste à faire nous allons
traîner je voudrais que tu ouvre grand
la bouche
ce alors même qu'ils chantent les
chemises leurs cadets cet âge même mon
casque bonbons casimir c'est tellement
bête et naïve que tu as pris
l'expression avoir un chat dans la gorge
au pied de la lettre alors que tout
simplement ça veut dire être en rond et
ne commencez pas à m'insulter il n'y a
pas que vous qui arriveront à varen chat
dans la gorge j'ai le droit moi aussi
d'avoir de lumières de toutes façons un
chat est un chat
voilà quasiment tous les choux et
prennent donne de moi s'il te plait
enlevez oui enfin réglé pour moi maxi
attend les enfants venaient quoi qu'est
ce qu'il avait dit
casimir avant de boire ce lait avec du
miel qui va nous chanter ta chanson les
enfants eux mêmes et installons nous sur
le nord les enfants mais en charge ce
n'était pas prévu enfin puisque c'est là
la demande générale d'accord je veux
bien alors musique 1
[Musique]
avec une chanson et un peu d'imagination
chaque 100 m notre île un floppy du
bonheur tranquille
meurtri
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
je m'appelle casini
j'ai la peau couleur orange
aussi
si l'on me dit maladroit
honte à moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis l esma tirs camille si j'aime la
glace au son choix c'est pourquoi c'est
mon droit
et bien casimiri n'y a pas finis ta
chance et non si je la termine aimons
les verts feront dire
pour moi d'aller s'asseoir maintenant on
veut moi
écouter assainir ta voix est si belle
que tu n'as pas besoin de lait avec du
miel tandis que moi l'admiration m'a
laissé sans voix
soit
[Musique]